[Musique]
alors vous y voyez peut-être pas
grand-chose mais en regardant bien
peut-être que vous allez distinguer
quelques formes qui vont vous rappeler
les cours de chimie du collège ou du
lycée
en fait ce que vous avez sous les yeux
là c'est la carte métabolique la plus
complète qui existe à ce jour c'est à
dire toutes les réactions chimiques et
toutes les molécules qu'elles
contiennent qui se passe naturellement
dans votre corps pour qu'il fonctionne
alors absolument tout est là en fait vos
sensations vos mouvements
votre digestion et même vos sentiments
comme l'amour et la tristesse et il faut
bien imaginer que tout ça ça se passe
naturellement dans votre corps dans
toutes vos cellules tout le temps sans
même que vous ayez besoin d'y penser je
trouve ça absolument énorme tout et
molécules en fait absolument tout vous
moi on est un ensemble de molécules
entre deux réactions chimiques et j'ai
le sentiment en fait que tout le monde
devrait s'en rappeler et pensez un peu
plus souvent parce qu'en fait ça nous
remet complètement sur un pied d'égalité
vous je suis désolé mais vous la voulez
être qu'un tas de molécules quand je dis
ça c'est pas du tout une insulte en fait
c'est même un peu le plus beau
compliment que je puisse vous faire
parce qu'en fait je suis biochimiste et
en fait c'était pas du tout le rêve de
ma vie non plus ce que je voulais être
pilote de formule 1 et je suis passé par
une carrière dans le tir à l'arc
en fait ce master de biochimie c'était
un peu la seule manière pour moi de
corriger le tir sur un projet scolaire
un peu bancal et après coup en fait même
s'il a fallu se manger cette carte
métabolique parker et que j'ai laissé
franchement quelques nuits je me dis
quelle chance finalement d'avoir pu
apprendre tout ça je me dis même que ça
devrait être obligatoire
en fait ça a complètement changé ma
perception du monde parce que déjà ça
m'a permis de me rends compte que moi
même j'étais qu'un sacré tas de déchets
auto compliments et qu'en plus ça m'a
permis de se mettre ce filtre se fit
moléculaire ce filtre chimique devant à
peu près tout ce que j'observe je me
suis quand même payant premier karting
parce que bon on n'oublie pas vraiment
ses rêves de formule ce que je vous
propose
c'est d'utiliser ce filtre et d'utiliser
les louanges une orange comme exemples
pour démontrer tout ça donc là à gauche
vous avez l'oranje qui est mise à la
poubelle par une usine qui fabrique du
jus d'orange et à droite vous avez un
zeste d'orange tout beau on est bien
d'accord qu'en fait c'est exactement la
même chose c'est-à-dire que physiquement
non mais moléculaire mans oui le zeste c
de la peau alors on peut se demander
pourquoi aujourd'hui encore il ya des
usines qui existent et qui fabrique jus
d'orange et qui jette la totalité de
leur peau d'orange
alors qu'en même temps on construit des
usines pour rester des oranges et jeter
toute la pulpe qui contient le jus ce
qu'en fait quand on fabrique jus
d'orange et ben on pèle l'oranje et on
jette la peau on garde la pulpe et après
on la presse et une fois qu'elle a été
pressé on la met à la poubelle également
et on se débarrasse d'une majorité de
l'eau qui est contenu dans le jeu aidé à
tout ça mis bout à bout ça fait quand
même 80 % de la masse d'une orange qui
rentre dans une usine qui en ressort par
la poubelle et finalement que les choses
soit belle ou moche elle nous apporte
exactement la même chose si elles
contiennent la même molécule s'ils
contiennent la même molécule
elles auront le même goût la même odeur
et les mêmes fonctions biologiques
cette peau d'orange l'a pas très belle
si on travaille un peu dessus on peut la
vendre à peu près 1 euro du kilo pour
les molécules qu'elle contient et c'est
principalement l'industrie des huiles
essentielles qui va être intéressés de
tout ça alors je sais pas si vous vous
rendez compte on en fait un euro du kilo
là c'est le même prix que l' orange donc
un déchet aussi cher que la matières
premières nobles c'est un peu finalement
comme si je vous disais que vos courses
eh bien vous avez le même valeur la même
valeur pardon que vos poubelles et bâle
usine qui jette ses peaux d'orange elle
en jette
huit mille tonnes par an donc 8 millions
de kilos et suivant un calcul
relativement simple 8 millions d'euros
normalement je veux pas qu'on parle
d'argent ça fait un peu bouger les
lignes il ya quelques années j'ai
travaillé dans l'industrie de la
parfumerie à grasse est en fait j'avais
pour mission de trouver une molécule
anti âge dans la rose alors la rose de
grâce on appelle aussi la rose de mai
c'est un peu la matière première la plus
noble qui
existe très chère très attractive on
s'en sert pour faire les plus grands
parfums de la planète
bah du coup assez naturellement on s'est
dit que plutôt que d'avoir à racheter
des tonnes de roses qui nous coûteraient
très cher on pouvait peut-être commencer
par faire nos propres poubelle est allé
chercher nos déchets de rose issus de la
parfumerie et voir s'il y avait pas
cette molécule dedans
et effectivement elle était dedans et
maintenant aller dans une crème
hydratante alors mettre une peau
d'orange à la poubelle c'est un peu le b
à ba
vous voyez pour une rose ça a généré
quelque chose ça a été la un petit peu
le début de la connexion si c'était
possible autant sur une orange
si banal que sur une rose qui est si
premium finalement c'est peut-être qu'on
pouvait le faire sur la totalité des
déchets végétaux qui existe de toutes
les plantes de tous les fruits de tous
les légumes et effectivement il
semblerait qu'il ait une solution
je vous propose de la voir comme ça
chaque déchet de chaque usine est en
quelque sorte la matière première idéale
d'une autre usine du notre industrie en
fait il suffit de trouver cette
industrie un peu comme la peau d'orange
qui a dû trouver l'industrie des huiles
essentielles
c'est ça le projet que j'anime au
quotidien le projet reversant ce fait
j'ai fondé une start up qui a pour
objectif et pour mission de rendre tous
les déchets sexy donc on les transforme
en nouveau produit des produits
techniques des produits stratégiques
pour les entreprises agro alimentaires
et cosmétiques qui peuvent du coup les
réutiliser et économiser beaucoup de
ressources naturelles est pas mal
d'argent au passage donc en fait les
peaux de bananes sont devenus des steaks
végétaux tout ce qui reste des graines
de lin après qu'on en ait pressé l'huile
c'est devenu une super fibre
épaississant tu pour toutes les pâtes à
tartiner et la pellicule de cacao qui
tombent quand on les tories fils fm pour
fabriquer le chocolat et ben ça nous
permet aujourd'hui d'aromatiser des
laits végétaux et des bières et vous
savez en fait le paradoxe dans tout ça
c'est que le modèle qui nous servent de
base le modèle dont on s'inspire le plus
pour développer notre activité
il n'est pas du tout éco responsable en
fait le modèle dont on sert le plus
c'est le pétrole fait
pétrole ce qui pollue énormément c'est
quand on utilise ces produits les
produits qu'on produit avec le pétrole
mais en fait sa fabrication
elle est relativement équilibré en fait
le pétrole on l'extrait du sol et on le
met dans une énorme marmite et cette
marmite
on l'a fait monter en température petit
à petit donc la température arrive un
peu près 20 degrés et là le pétrole
commence à bulles et s'il bull est bien
c'est qu'il ya des gaz qui s'échappe
ces gaz on les récupère on les met dans
des bouteilles et c'est le propane et le
butane et là la température continue de
monter et à l'arrivée au bout d'un
moment à 150 degrés à 150 degrés c les
essences qui s'échappe et les essences
et basses et les sens c'est celle qu'on
vient de la voiture la température
continue de monter et là on arrive à peu
près à 300° vous allez me dire que c'est
impossible c'est beaucoup trop facile
pour que ce soit vrai en fait c'est le
gasoil qui s'échappait et la température
continue de monter évidemment faut faire
bouger les avions donc le kérosène
arrive et s'échappe
enfin le fuel le voyez le fioul il est
très épais et très visqueux très noir
c'est pour ça qui s'évapore en dernier
et vous pensez probablement qu'à la
femme saab et il reste un déchet au fond
de la cuve et qu on le mettrait à la
poubelle alors effectivement il reste
quelque chose au fond de la cuve ne
l'est pas du tout à la poubelle parce
que ce qui reste au fond de la cuve en
fait là c'est les bitumes ce qui nous
sert à faire toutes les routes pour
utiliser tous les produits du pétrole
envoyé en fait dans une matière première
le pétrole eh ben on a réussi à créer
six à dix produits qu'on absolument tous
révolutionner notre civilisation
donc le chauffage les transports et même
toutes les routes qui permettent
d'utiliser ces moyens de transport du
coup je vous propose de voir le pétrole
peut être pas comme le modèle à abattre
abattre pardon et du coup de voir
repartir d'une page blanche mais
peut-être comme le modèle idéal et qu'en
fait on aurait juste à changer de ce
modèle la matière première
ce serait plus le pétrole et dans ce
modèle tous les déchets tous les sous
produits trouverait une nouvelle utilité
dans un nouveau marché
un peu comme le bitume finalement qui
était le déchet du pétrole ça
désacralise pas mal non en fait si je
désacralise totalement et que je suis
honnête avec vous je dois vous avouer
que même si je passe la totalité de mon
temps libre dans la nature
mes convictions environnementales c'est
pas du tout elles qui sont à l'origine
de mon activité en fait de ce concept de
cette start up
la vérité c'est que si vous voyez
aujourd'hui comme un petit héros de
l'écologie j'étais surtout là pour me
faire pas mal de cash
je vendais cher des choses dont personne
ne voulait les déchets il suffisait
juste de trouver cette personne
en fait ça me ferait tellement de voir
toutes ses usines dans lesquelles il y
avait de la valeur perdue que je me
disais tout simplement que cette valeur
ça pouvait devenir la mienne et que si
c'était les 8 millions d'euros que l'
usine qui jette les peaux d'orange met à
la poubelle assises était dans ma poche
ça me posait aucun souci alors c'était
très marrant au début c'était même
flatteur d'avoir l'impression d'être le
premier et pensé par tous d'être ce
premier explorateur et puis assez vite
ça m'a quand même pas mal écoeuré ce
qu'en fait du premier explorateur ont
bien assez vite l'unique témoin d'un
énorme problème
tous ces produits toutes ces montagnes
de déchets c'est des choses qui sont
produites en utilisant la terre en
utilisant des tonnes d'énergie et qui
sont produites par des gens et qu'on
valorise a à peine 20 % de ce qu'elles
sont alors je sais pas si vous imaginez
vous être un agriculteur et vendre une
orange en sachant que de toute façon 80%
de tous sa part à la poubelle mais en
fait moi je trouve ça super insultant et
du coup j'ai vu des centaines de tonnes
de pétards de framboise qui aurait pu
donner une superbe île pour la
cosmétique
des dizaines de tonnes de poudre de
cannelle qui était même pas utilisé
alors qu'on aurait pu les utiliser comme
poudre de cannelle tout simplement et
8000 tonnes de podor est en fait c'est
là qu'elle est née ma conscience
écologique sur le terrain du coup pour
alimenter votre réflexion je vous
propose vous de vous laisser avec
quelques chiffres que je trouve très
parlant demain si une usine pétrolière
gaspillé à peu près 5% du pétrole qui
rentrait chez elle en fait elle
fermerait dans la semaine pour l' orange
c'est 80 pour cent de tout ça qu'on
gaspille et je comprends pas pourquoi on
s'y autorise 7% des émissions de co2
globales sont liées à l'agriculture
principalement parce qu'elle consomme
beaucoup de pétrole mais il faut bien se
dire quand même que 80 pour cent de tout
ça dans le cas de laurence sert
absolument à rien parce que sa part à la
poubelle en 2050 on sera à peu près 9
milliards sur terre et du coup de massue
milliards de bouches à nourrir
pour bien nourrir tout le monde c'est à
dire vous et moi qui probablement nous
serons déjà bien notre faim mais aussi
tous ceux qui mangent pas encore à leur
fin faudra qu'on augmente d'à peu près
70% la production agricole
suivant le modèle actuel en fait si on
fait tous ces calculs très complexe on
se rend assez vite compte que le
résultat lui est très simple c'est à
dire que c'est impossible c'est juste
une impasse il n'y a pas la place sur
terre pour neuf milliards de personnes
et pour toutes les terres agricoles pour
les nourrir lorsque assez marrant ou pas
en fait c'est que l'onu a identifié
en parallèle que 50% de tout ce qu'on
produit aujourd'hui fini à la poubelle
c'est à dire qu'entre un champ et notre
assiette la moitié de ce qu'on produit
par à la poubelle et je peux vous
garantir après avoir analysé une
centaine d' usine en personne que dans
l'industrie c'est encore pire que çà
mais en fait elle est là la solution
sert qu'en fait c'est 50% là qu'il faut
absolument aller chercher pour combler
les 70% qui manquent
alors vous voyez en fait le constat lui
il est pas vraiment glorieux mais la
solution elle existe et aussi bizarre
qu'elle sonne en fait débat le futur il
est dans nos déchets alors si ça vous
fait sourire finalement de voir votre
poubelle comme une mine d'or ou une
boule de cristal et que ça gênait un peu
d'optimisme même chez vous voir un peu
de bonheur là sachez que ces trois là
ils ont aussi leur place sur la carte
métaboliques et qui sont là alors à vous
de jouer merci beaucoup
[Musique]